la suite de la visite d'état de jacques
chirac en arabie saoudite c'est la
première fois qu'un chef d'état y reçut
devant le conseil consultatif saoudien
le président de la république en a
profité pour saluer l'esprit de réforme
qui commence à toucher le royaume
mais l'essentiel est ailleurs la france
souhaite mieux implantés ces entreprises
dans ce pays en pleine expansion
le contact est pris mais pas de commande
ferme pour l'instant véronique sainte
livre francis manger aux portes du
désert dans l'ancienne cité de ryad le
président de la république et bernadette
chirac
revêtu de l'abaya traditionnelle ont
admiré le berceau de la famille al saoud
une marque de respect un préalable
indispensable
la cordialité des parfums les intérêts
sont partagés avec la manne du pétrole
le roi abdellah espère prendre de
vitesse les terroristes avec un
développement qui profiterait à tous
quand jacques chirac
c'est l'occasion rêvée de pousser les
entreprises françaises de l'armement
alors que le contexte régional reste
marqué par temps d'incertitudes la
france se doit de marquer sa
disponibilité à s'engager plus avant
encore que par le passé pour contribuer
à la sécurité de votre pays
possible ces rappels ou matérielles
manquent et puis il ya aussi le
gigantesque projet d'une raffinerie 5
milliards de dollars je suis optimiste
sur la conclusion d'un délai
relativement prochain ce soir jacques
chirac servant partisan du dialogue des
cultures à visiter l'exposition d'objets
islamique prêtée par le louvre dans la
poudrière du proche orient le président
de la république continue de croire que
seuls le dialogue et le respect des
différences feront obstacle au fanatisme
et au terrorisme
un message bien perçue ici en arabie
saoudite